what's going on guys
Netflix Jessica Jones the final trailer
dropped the shows coming soon
what's going on with Jessica Jones what
the f is Jessica Jones we have a couple
of guys that know a thing or two about a
thing or two here to explain it to us
our first guest he is a filmmaker a
comic book writer the head geek at geek
scape net Jonathan London and he is the
perfect guy to talk about this stuff
he's the host of Marvel movie news Matt
Keith thank you for being here oh thank
you for having me I was honored to get a
call
it's Jessica Jones how much of Jessica
Jones coming to Netflix is due to
daredevil and the success of daredevil I
think it was all part of the same
package okay when daredevil was
announced it was part of Jessica Jones
an iron fist and in Luke Cage Power Man
we're gonna get all four of those and
they were gonna culminate in a defender
series so we're gonna get five series
yeah right and Jessica Jones talking
about like her origins in this character
she has connections throughout the
Marvel Universe right Jessica Jones was
a character that went to school with
Peter Parker she was a character we
never heard of she had a giant crush on
Peter Parker who always in the
background never heard from and then on
a family trip she her family was run off
the road
chemicals spilled onto her and now she
she has super strength can fly and she's
not quite bulletproof but her skin is
pretty tough and like her dad worked for
Tony Stark yeah yeah so just like weird
connection yeah yeah yeah throughout the
universe the series was called alias yes
she was a private investigator I was
investigating things that involve
superheroes series only ran from 2001 to
2004 it was part of a Marvel line called
max which meant it had a lot more adult
themes a lot more violence some sex but
would you call Matt it was like more of
a regret II realistic style Oh David
Mack style and it really made it a
serious series and then when we met the
villain who's gonna be in the series the
purple man yeah it's it gets really dark
this is this is this kilgrave yeah yeah
tell us a little bit about him the main
villain in the comics is not mind
control so much as its control over your
will so it's not like I want you to go
kill that person he says you want to go
kill that person and then you go do it
so he takes over your brain and makes
you want to do the things that you do
how does he cross paths with Jessica
Jones I don't know how it's gonna happen
in the series but in in the alias series
yeah it was one of her investigations
that these things were starting to
happen that were not characteristic of
the people that were doing them and when
she investigates that she realizes that
killgrave is responsible for it and this
stuff is pretty dark so he's not using
his mind control for good things and
nice things and like I just want to help
the economy or schools no and that's
like that's the PTSD that Jessica Jones
ends up getting and dealing with a like
alias starts with her having already
experienced kilgrave in that way
somewhere in her past cuz now the
talking raccoon it's certainly it's not
as fun as that was this is a whole
nother ballgame Jessica Jones seems like
a real ballsy chick she she drinks she
like you know she screws she does
whatever the hell she wants tell me a
little bit about that so I mean when
again like when you first see her she's
like this wholesome like haha kind of
character I'm um killgrave happens and
takes all that away from her she was
sent to go kill daredevil and as she got
further and further away from kilgrave's
influence she was like wait what am i
doing so she still has these powers on
she wants to use them for good so she's
kind of underground uh this is
definitely not Supergirl she used to be
Supergirl she was a character named
jewel like that's how that's how in bed
right she rose and she was part of like
one of the lower tier Avengers teams
uh-huh she can go toe-to-toe with Luke
Cage been to jail had a experimental
operation done to him got injected with
some stuff and now has it's like steel
strong skin in Luke 8 as a kind of end
up as the captain of the defenders talk
to me about how we see the defenders
coming together because there's been no
mention of the defenders yet in the
Marvel TV series we're talking about or
has them or has their okay yeah lay it
on me so in this series we've got jeryn
hogarth coming and played by carrie anne
moss
uh-huh and she is actually Danny rands
right-hand man for like since the
beginning of iron fist like he was
introduced like the fourth issue in okay
and he runs all of the business
helps Danny around with the business he
was as his deceased father's business
partner for the RAND Corporation and he
ends up being a legal representative for
Heroes for Hire which is basically what
the defenders is gonna be so now there's
like a gender swap Korean moss is
playing jeryn hogarth and yeah he's okay
totally cool with that so who's whose
iron fist tell us a little bit about
iron fist Danny Rand studied in the
mystical city of Shu Kunlun kun LUN I
almost said the dragon he defeated the
dragon Shu Lau and took his heart out of
him and that's where the power of the
iron fist comes from as a mystical power
but that's that so his powers that he's
got like iron fists and he's like this
3,000 level
martial artist but he's also a pretty
wealthy industrialist right huh
almost toe-to-toe with Tony Stark as far
as being wealthy go so he's got the
resources to back a super team yeah Wow
so um for the uninitiated would you say
the defenders are kind of like a
street-level Avengers yeah they're kind
of doing Heroes for Hire and collab
defenders
these are street-level rooftop jumping
superheroes yeah what are some of the
things that haven't been introduced yet
that we should look forward to we do
know that Rosario Dawson's coming back
as night nurse hopefully for more than a
few episodes I mean yeah awesome and
daredevil totally the glue is starting
to be there and then when you go back to
daredevil you saw that they're starting
to lean towards the whole gel that's
keeping all this together right you saw
the introduction of like the steel
serpent insignia on the heroin and
Madame Gao is selling so it's all
starting to lean towards this mega I
think street-level ninja fight yeah
that's gonna happen the defendant row
fight and like the boroughs of Manhattan
and keep in mind that all these TV
actors have clauses in their contract
that if they are gonna be asked to
appear in some of the Marvel films they
have to so we know basically the big
picture of the formation of the
defenders but how do we see it happening
in the immediate future with Punisher
daredevil Jessica Jones sort of
interweaving and coming together the
defenders are gonna be these four heroes
that have an idealistic view of what
their job is even though it's not nasty
and gross it's mostly going to be
Jessica Jones Luke Cage iron fist and
daredevil I think Punisher is gonna be
kind of on the outskirts okay so if I
can break down what you guys said
Jessica Jones private investigator turns
to fighting crime teams with Luke Cage
and they're fighting killgrave yeah it
sounds well right and it's all in Hell's
Kitchen that's in New York yeah yeah
yeah and there's going to be a lot of
drinking and a lot of violence sure
maybe a little sex thrown into are you
excited for Jessica Jones let us know in
the comments section below and the
coolest answer we're gonna send you a
screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
my esteemed guest
Jonathan London Matt key thank you for
coming and talking to us and guys if you
love TV and you want to hear even more
about it you need to check out TV fights
which is coming to screen junkies Plus
which kicks off November 17th
check the description in the comments
below to find out more you know a little
bit about TV fights right I do I do I've
been on it it is intense and terrifying
intense and terrifying just like movie
fights you know and love I want to thank
you for watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me
up on Twitter bye bye screen junkies
plus a new network created entirely for
movie fans featuring shows from the most
epic voices and movies and TV